hi many of you might be like me that's
out of shape I actually used to be a
very active person I played sports I
worked out and then since the internet
came along I haven't been doing that at
all I decided to take part in this fun
event hosted by GE and Howcast
it's called the healthy imagination
YouTube a physical challenge official
it's all about better health for more
people so here's where you guys come in
over the next two days I'm going to be
taking suggestions from you on things
that I should do to get healthy now I
can be anything from running two miles a
day to taking the yoga class to eating
healthy for an entire month straight
hopefully you guys will come up with
some more creative ideas than that I'll
be taking three of your suggestions and
then posting a video of you trying to
complete those tasks
whoever Scott men's like big I'll be
sure to give you a shout out this is a
competition between all of us youtubers
involved in this event so whoever gets
the most views most comments most
ratings will get a donation in their
name $10,000 to the Millennium promise
charity so get watching who let me know
what kind of crazy things you guys want
me to try to do to get healthy you want
to learn more about the
healthymagination competition check out
youtube.com slash podcast for more
information and to see what other
youtubers are involved alright so what
should I do to get healthy